Io non ho mai visto nella mia vita così
tanta roba tutta accorpata messe insieme
siamo finiti in un basement sotterraneo
dove c'è un ristorante dove il tizio che
il proprietario ristorante è uno
youtuber che non si capisce se questi
sono i suoi video non si capisce se
arabo turco si capisce un cazzo è
simpaticissimo i nostri video
ci ha portato qui i complimenti eh buono
buono
ti piace
last Three Days in Tokyo my boys sono
arrivato alla porta dopo aver sbagliato
hotel perché ho sbagliato hotel mi han
portato a shibuya che c'è uno stesso
hotel è la stessa catena Sono entrato ho
detto ciao Mi ha detto vattene a
e sono arrivato a Shield qui dove c'è
notai con lo stesso nome
Ed eccoci qua con l'ultima stanza quindi
gli ultimi tre giorni ripasserò qua
dentro
vi devo dire No a parte gli scherzi
carino Cioè non è male è piccola ma
caratteristica un po' come la prima io
la vista bello bello
Va bene va bene onesto più di tre giorni
li passiamo qua ragazzi cioè non isti
infatti cioè la stanza albergo è un po'
al cesso vediamo il cesso
passabile Mi dispiace molto dirlo ma in
questi ultimi giorni mi rammaricano
perché non vedere tutto questo per non
so quanto altro tempo
di peso Però è stato un viaggio
incredibile tornerò presto Cioè non farò
passare più tutto questo tempo cioè
vorrei venire qua Una volta all'anno lo
so che molti di voi mi stanno dicendo un
bastardatch cosa ci avete ragione però
vi faccio i video dai almeno vi porto un
po' con me giusto così ma questo posto è
casa mia
c'è la zebra a Tarantula il black
Scorpion come voglio prendere un
pacchetto di questi Pensa che stronzo Se
compri souvenir così togli l'etichetta e
uno lo apre c'è una tarantola gigantesca
merda ragazzi che roba di merda No dai
anche ci sono anche i pupazzi schifo
ora non so felice ma tanto tanto
io lascio sempre il finale dei miei
viaggi per i souvenir per appunto i
regali che faccio i miei amici perché se
no me li porto appresso per tutto il
viaggio non ha senso Quindi questi
ultimi due giorni a Tokyo vi passerò a
prendere sovenire regali Stiamo andando
Anna keano Broadway Anzi ci siamo già
una canoa brodo e ora ve la faccio
vedere l'obiettivo andare da mandarache
che il negozio di action figures più
grosso del Giappone e quello dei manga
che avete visto l'altra volta ma questo
solo di action figure Meno male che non
c'è gente ecco qua Infatti
a posto tutto questo ho perso già in
metro Sono riuscito a perdere J in metro
vi chiedete come è possibile non lo so
Le metro sono grosse mi sono perso J che
è uscito dalla metro e sta venendo in
taxi Ed eccolo qua ragazze abbiamo
trovato il mandarà molto prima io in
metro che lui in taxi Però vabbè
dovrebbero esserci un miliardo di action
figures ma vedo solo manga quindi forse
mi hanno preso per il culo ah no ragazzi
in realtà c'è anche la parte Action
Figure però è molto compressa ci sembra
tipo un'edicola prima non ho mai visto
nella mia vita così tanta roba tutta
accorpata messa insieme incredibile però
non è un negozio gigante di action
figure cioè molto meglio quello di via
chiavara quindi adesso che arriverà a
Jedi dovrò dire che abbiamo sbagliato
dopo che ha preso anche un taxi e siamo
in giro da un'oretta
Va bene allora Ragazzi ho scoperto
guardandomi anche in giro che
effettivamente non c'è un negozio solo
Cioè non è un mandarà anche solo ma ce
ne sono tanti quindi ognuno dentro le
sue cose ad esempio questo c'ha un sacco
di action figures
hanno trovato a caso e stavo dicendo che
non c'è un negozio e ce ne sono tanti
qua non si capisce neanche tu qua penso
che tu faccia degli ordini Cioè tu vai
lì e dici ok ordine numero x lo ti
arriva e vai a ritirarlo una cosa
incredibile qua un altro Reaction figo
cioè c'è tanta roba non si capisce una
sega Questo è uno dei più carini Secondo
me sono contento perché finalmente trovo
un Action Figure di Jojo molto contento
solo che la carta per metterlo per per
imballarlo non c'è scritto ti amo molto
bene e mi metto a bloggare questa cosa
molto importante che questo è l'unica
Action Figure di Death Note che io ho
trovato da quando sono in Giappone non
c'è niente Ce n'è altre incredibile cioè
roba incredibile roba di detto questa è
Misa Questa è light questo è Mello
incredibile vabbè top Gen è rimasto in
albergo e probabilmente è morto però noi
siamo in giro a shinjuku C'è una vista
della Madonna E Jay che è esperto di
cucina thailandese è stato un sacco di
volte in Thailandia mi sta consigliando
la tonkai la Tom cacai che dall'immagine
effettivamente rende giustizia il nome
invece dal sapore amici molto buono
possiamo fare un tour della mia stanza
d'albergo ai ragazzi e questo è il
concetto che loro hanno di rifare la
stanza lo so perché ieri ci ho dormito e
non me l'hanno rifatta il loro concetto
è mettere una borsa con gli asciugamani
e con una bella scritta e fattelo tu ho
trasferito tutti i miei vestiti nella
valigia di Daniel e Jacopo perché la mia
valigia è completamente vuota adesso e
sarà dedicata ai souvenir ai pupazzi
action figures eccetera quindi oggi
andiamo in giro per ultimare i regali da
fare ai miei Friends
abbiamo comprato
l'incomprabile Cioè voi non avete idea A
parte che siamo qua da che abbaiano e
abbiamo comprato
l'incomprabile Grazie allora mi hanno
fatto spendere perché non volevo
spendere spendere
no se non ho speso almeno €200 oggi
intanto sto negozio Vabbè che è questo
che quel negozio mendia chiabara venite
qua ehm Non uscite più ragazzi è
bellissimo Guarda come come in macchina
che senso fa stare la chiabara andiamo a
cena siamo in un palazzo al
trentottesimo piano perché ci ha portato
qua a Jay Grazie Mi sembra un po'
esagerato Ragazzi mi sembra un po'
esagerato ma tanto paga J
ok
sì sì Porca che succede tutto
no Comunque mi aspettavo di tutto tranne
che un bagno così penso sia un po' Too
Much Speriamo che nessuno abbia il
binocolo nel mentre che
sto pisciando perché sarebbe un po'
strano Allora ragazzi vi rendo partecipe
di questa mia serata l'ultima dove sono
tornato appunto nella stanza d'albergo
per mettere a posto la valigia sto
mettendo tutte le cianfrusaglie e robe
che ho comprato tra cui quando sono
andato da chiabra Mi sono innamorato di
questo una sorta di action figures si
chiama Action Plastic Model kit del
Metal Gear per chi non gioca la Metal
Gear non sa di cosa sto parlando quello
è il Metal Gear Reflex ti ho preso anche
questa che del Metal Gear Rey quindi
Metal Gear 2 io pensavo tirai fuori
dalla scatola le action figures ok
non è così non è così tiri fuori dalla
scatola questo
Ragazzi ma che cazzo è mi hanno dato
pacchi di questa roba che non ho
minimamente idea di come io possa cioè
non ho idea comunque solo questo mi
tiene spazio mi mi occupa tutta la
valigia solo questo ok Ragazzi mi sa che
non riuscirò a vloggare molto nel
ritorno perché sono completamente sfatto
ho dormito tipo 4 ore e sono in
aeroporto e devo tornare in Italia
eh le cose belle finiscono nonostante io
vi abbia detto che avrei bloccato poco
ho fatto i controlli che gli ho passati
e poi sono arrivato dalla parte dopo i
controlli all'aeroporto e mi sono
sdraiato qui perché all'aeroporto di
aneda ci sono
le sdraio morbide cioè
Ieri ero da Chiavari e stamattina
a Milano
comunque praticamente mi fa sempre
strano Quando torno da un viaggio così
grande svegliarmi il giorno dopo in casa
come se niente fosse sostanzialmente
come se fosse stato tutto un sogno
perché i ragazzi se ci pensate essere
dall'altra parte del mondo e poi il
giorno dopo di trovarsi a casa come se
niente fosse e sembra magia poi se pensi
tutto il viaggio che hai fatto che ho
fatto dove volevo soltanto morire non
era magia è stato è stato peso ma ne è
valsa la pena ragazzi sono riuscita ad
imbarcare i pezzi del Metal Gear
Che cazzo devo fare qua